second hand was successfully positioned
as a solution for everyone and has no
barriers all types of content
all ages in all
very different regions in mexico and that
is why we now have one million daily users
and we are the leader in classifieds in
mexico we have more houses  more cars more
smartphones and we have all the ranges
of products where the deal is made in
an extraordinary meeting between
Mexicans
we decided to move our business to the cloud
to have a more functional and
easy-to-use support and at the same time scale
our operations in a
safe and profitable way  and reliable with the least
possible impact we compare the options
available on the market we live that
I put a cloud platform we were able to save
up to 15% without making big
changes spend a lot of time
adapting to the new platform with
automatic scalability we can not
say at night and adjust in  the morning
when we only need 25% of the
power of the infrastructure  ure our
journey to the cloud has been a
seamless experience on google+ we have been able to
deliver a more reliable and
faster service to buyers and sellers
our innovation in our customers
found a new home in the cloud